hello my name is Caleb bindi and welcome
back to game review today I wanted to go
over a bit of a classic between Karpov
and Kasparov now of course and these two
legends have played countless games
against each other in countless World
Championships and among them themselves
they have gathered quite a few brilliant
moves in these games and the brilliant
move was actually played by Karpov in
this game and I was reminded of it
looking at a game played very recently
today between Bobby Cara Juana and chemo
raja baath and either that has its own
video up already or that video is coming
soon so be on the lookout for that and
despite you know the one brilliant move
by Karpov this is a very interesting
game in its own right for everything
else that happened as well so why don't
we take a look at it the game started
with Karpov playing the English with c4
we have the symmetrical with c5 Knight
f3 Knight of 6 we have Knight c3 and now
d5 by Gary
so black breaks the symmetry pretty
quickly here by playing the move d5
breaking in the center before white has
a chance to we have C takes d5 Knight
takes d5 and now after the move d4 there
are a couple different paths the game
can go down in this case cat's probe
juices to take on c3 we have B takes c3
and now after g6 can we get sort of a
grünfeld looking position in fact white
can't actually play the movie for here
and we might just directly be in the
green fell defense now but instead
Karpov chooses the slightly more solid
move III the point being we just build a
strong hold on this d4 pawn and we try
to use this d4 pawn to just stunt in
this dark squared bishop from getting
into the game Bishop g7 was played
anyways now Bishop d3 just natural
development by Karpov
if castles castles and Queen c7 by Gary
aiming for a move such as e5 also eyeing
this C file just a little bit Brooke b1
now was car pops choice putting the rook
on the half-open file isn't usually not
a bad idea
pressuring the b7 pond a little bit and
now b6 and now
Karpov played a very important move that
I wanted to just briefly mention here
whenever you get a position like this
where you have sort of your big dark
square pawn structure with the white
pieces this Bishop becomes a hugely
important piece for the white player the
reason being this Bishop is probably
White's best minor piece in most cases
looking at these two beautiful open
diagonals
now after b6 when Wyatt when Black has
not developed in the night or the bishop
black is actually threatening to play
the move Bishop e6 trading off his
lights grid bishop for your beautiful
light squared bishop of course this is a
trade that white very much isn't
interested in in most cases so Karpov
plays the move Queen e2 and this is a
great way to guard this square and
prevent this trade from coming on the
board with that idea refuted black now
continued with the move rook to d8
now Karpov place is a really interesting
move Bishop to e4 and I just kind of
talked up preventing this idea of Bishop
a6
but now if bit should be 7 I think
Karpov was actually planning to capture
this guy and the point now is while
these bishops do get exchanged this
Queen is very very poorly placed on the
B file and moves like D takes c5 are
going to be threatened almost
immediately Bishop a3 another idea and
this was sort of car pops idea giving up
this bishop anyways but getting this
immediate displacement of the black
Queen Kasparov actually wasn't
interested in this going for Bishop 1/6
instead sort of counterpunching one
threat to the rook with another the move
c4 comes on the board now for Karpov and
just sort of manually blocking off this
Bishop no knight c6 and Karpov comes up
with the move d5 so despite his initial
blocking off of the dark squared bishop
cast or Karpov now totally opens up this
diagonal but only after removing the
rook from the a1 square and sort of
leaving this Bishop instead of fighting
on granite biting on thin air is the
term I like to use miss Bishop looks
nice but is it doing too much it's a
little bit unclear
it is controlling these squares
but there's nothing occupying these
squares for it to attack now it was
possible for Casper up to just move this
night directly attacking the c4 pawn but
instead he had bigger designs in mind he
said I want to put this night on the d4
square well this seems pretty impossible
right now but not after the forced line
that Kasparov entered he chose the move
at 5 in this case a 5 hits this Bishop
and this bishops most national square is
d3 to defend the c4 pawn but now if you
move e5 actually comes on the board to
buy Kasparov the point being if you
capture this Knight well then the movie
for and this is going to be quite nice
for black actually so v4 is more or less
forced by white to block this off and
now we do see Kasparov get this Knight
to the score he wanted initially on d4
this Knight is just a little bit too
powerful
to let remain here so Karpov takes it
off the board Knight takes d4 C takes d4
and we have now a very interesting
structure in the position white has this
protective past D pawn black has this
protective past deep on now the good
news for white is that the C pawn is
actually also on a half-open file that
means if Wyatt can somehow deal with
this a 7 and b6 pawn is actually going
to have connected passed pawns in c5 and
d5 and that's going to be such a major
advantage in any endgame that white
could kind of steer the game into these
pawns are in the center are going to be
devastating if they can get rolling now
that's not to say that black has an
awful position here for one if white
wants to capture on f5 you can't really
take twice immediately do two takes on
c4 actually probably with the Queen to
prevent Bishop d3 and then this D pawn
would fall so if you take G takes you
are actually allowing sort of the same
mobility for black now so Karpov wasn't
interested in that
and instead chose the move Bishop g5
rook f8 and now while these pawns for
black are sort of blocked they do allow
him to get sort of the
Old Kings Indian counter play on the
kingside and Kasparov of course a hugely
experienced Kings Indian defense player
is now happy to play for checkmate
that's exactly what happens in this game
so white playing on the Queen side with
this advant advantage black plank on the
Kings side now trying to push these guys
all the way forward rook F c1 was
White's choice and now black would love
to play the move f4 but unfortunately
this is just a little bit too friendly
allowing white to play the move
c5 surgery immediately and get very
active play on the Queen side for
example takes takes takes on c5 rook b5
regaining the pawn and this is going to
be I think a good position for white so
Ric c1 was a severe enough threat that
f4 could not be played and so it was met
with heroic a to see a sort of preparing
to meet this with B takes e5 Bishop d2
now does evacuate this Bishop before f4
comes on the board and rook f7 was the
move by Kasparov just allowing these
rooks a little bit more mobility by
having them on separate ranks they can
sort of double up wherever they're
needed and now Kasparov comes up with
the most natural plan in the position
you want to break through with c5 your
opponent is guarding the square with
this be pawn so very sensible now a4 a5
breaking down this pawn on d6 whenever
you see this structure a76 a4 a5 that's
sort of the very natural way to break it
down create weaknesses on the Queen side
Kasparov wasted no time however taking
on e4 now we have Queen takes e4 and
rook c2 f8 we now see the point of rook
f7 coming through with pressure along
the F file now
Karpov felt it was the right moment to
play f3 keeping this pawn well defended
by the cheap on and now Bishop to c8 is
very natural rerouting this Bishop to
some more active squares a5 does come on
the board for Karpov the natural
continuation of his plan we have Bishop
f5 Queen over to e2 and now actually the
move rook e8 on the board perhaps
hinting at playing
some before ideas which would of course
open two very key diagonals at once not
interested in letting this happen
Karpov prevents efore in my favorite way
by making it illegal this is my favorite
way to prevent moves that are annoying
to you if you make them illegal you can
be pretty darn well sure they're not
going to be played and now Bishop f8 is
a very clever rerouting of the dark
squared bishop fort Queen D 3 is
blockading both pawns now and we do see
Bishop c5 now rook a1 is car pops choice
sort of preparing for the opening of the
a file we have Queen d7 which I'm not
going to lie to you is a little bit too
mysterious for me to understand
Kasparov plays Queen d7 followed by
Queen c8 and I just quite simply don't
fully understand the ramifications of
these moves in the game
riki one was played by Karpov which is
sensible defending e4 even further
perhaps even pressuring me five
indirectly and now we do see Queen c8 by
Kasparov now
Karpov plays the Karpov move as I like
to call it and that is King H 1 of
course stepping out of any potential
discoveries by this Bishop also just
directly improving this King by moving
this King into the corner you actually
clear the g1 square for the rook which
can be a very useful to fender you also
remove the King from any potential
threats on the G file where this punim
would end up pinned and this G pond
which is a key defender of these light
squares would be immobilized so king h1
a very very useful move in most of these
positions where you're kind of facing a
devastating King side attack so nice
move by Karpov now we do see this sort
come back over to c7 perhaps you know
blacks play has been stalled for the
moment so he comes back over to the
Queen side to I the c4 pawn this work
now comes back to be one more slightly
mysterious rook moves by Karpov but I'm
the b v square I'm the b6 pawn once
again with Rick c7 black is sort of
hinted that he's interested in moving
this bishop and attacking the C pawn the
rook b1 discourages that by pressuring
b6
qg7 now is Kasparov's choice perhaps
preparing a sort of pong storm rick e to
see one now does defend the c-pawn even
further bishop takes e4 and now f takes
e4 and this change of structure is
pretty relevant this allows the F file
to be totally open now this F 3 square
is not going to be a square it's not
going to be occupied by a pawn which
allows black to sort of invade along the
F file directly then rook f7 by black
Queen g3 was Karpov idea pressuring
stuff on the Kings side himself and now
B takes a5 was finally played by
Kasparov and I think this B takes a v
move may have been actually a a slight
mistake
as it stood there was no open file on
the Queen side and so it wasn't exactly
clear how White was going to get this
act of counter play on the King side in
this case though now after Bishop takes
a 5 the stroke is already well placed on
the B file and we will see that it does
come into the game at a later date the
point for Kasparov was he did want to
divert this bishop temporarily allowing
the stroke to come in to f4 attacking
this efore pawn and this is a very
sensible point because now after rook e1
we do see even more concrete play by
Castro of taking advantage once again of
this bishops placement to make more
direct threats Bishop comes back to d2
this rooks hit so back to f7 but now
after Queen d3 Karpov is sort of
comfortably consolidated his position
with this Queen well-placed to defend
both weaknesses
riki to f8 now is still trying to make
use of this F file rook sorry h3 by
Karpov gives this King a flight square
also defends the g4 square and points
out that this dark square bishop is
capable of defending the dark squares
around the King and so by putting the
pawns on the light squares Karpov is
using them to control the other color
complex this doesn't love the move rook
f2 but now Ric a1 by whites you have
Queen over to f6 and rook g1 now does
come on the board and at first glance
Kasparov's total control of the F file
does seem to be sort of dominating but
after further review you do see that
black is really not generating any
direct threats immediately on the Kings
side in fact all of these squares are
covered so f2 is really the only square
that Karpov has available to him to sort
of launch this attack and because of
that it's actually going to be these C
and D ponds that are slightly more
relevant in my opinion Karpov is not
going to sit idly by he is going to
start generating in these threats on the
Queen side now that all of blacks major
pieces sort of been placed on the F file
h5 was the continuation for Kasparov
sort of launching this pawn storm to
break down this defensive setup now
wreak a five very annoyingly hits this
Bishop this is enough to divert the
Queen back to e7 if you play the move
Bishop e6 you're asking for rugby 5 when
c5 is a very serious threat so Queen e7
instead and now rook over to be one sort
of one attacking piece has left the
Kings side or at least left the F file
so one defending piece is leaving as
well to generate more threats on the
Queen side age four now by Kasparov is
creating a strong hold on the g3 square
and now we see rook a six by Karpov and
perhaps actually this was the moment for
Karpov to play a very interesting move
Bishop e1 now after rook F for this
Bishop King come back to d2 and rook to
f2 there is some sort of interesting
line that I saw here yeah I think it is
actually rook up to b5 you know it turns
out the white king is safe enough that
you can divert even more pieces away
from the King and really go for these c5
ideas in the game though we didn't see
that instead we saw rook a6 trying to
create more concrete threats on the
Kings side now after rook a to f7 we do
see rook over to c6 and I don't mind
this way of playing either by a Karpov
Queen f8 was played in the game
now this Queen is kind of perfectly
placed defending both the Bishop on c5
and creating threats on the Kings
we saw this work come back over to g1 we
saw Bishop e7 by Kasparov now rookie six
by Karpov King aged seven this should be
one trying to hit this guy
this allows rook F one though and Karpov
now repeats once especially comes back
to c5 this comes back to c6 and I
honestly can't tell you if Karpov was
sort of repeating going for a draw here
or if he was sort of biding his time
waiting for Kasparov to sort of make the
first move not yet ready to accept the
draw what I do know is that this turned
out to be a great way of playing for
Karpov practically because Kasper oh
I've got a bit impatient here and went
for a stunning rook sacrifice with the
move rook 7 to f3 this one is sort of a
a screamer here this is the most direct
way to try to just checkmate the white
king
the point is G takes f 3 rook takes F 3
and while this rook is open now we do
see that the King side is totally
collapsing for white and at first glance
there's seemingly nothing we can do
about it Karpov inserts Rick c7 check
you see King h8 and now it's almost like
there's nothing that white can do to
prevent to prevent checkmate aside from
you know going a little bit crazy like
Queen takes f3 check and just going for
this type of position here which is
obviously not going to be enough for a
win or you know kind of abandoning the
game altogether going for Rho takes g6
with check check check check check
and and a draw that being said there is
one move that Gary Kasparov missed and
one move that Anatoly Karpov did not
miss so I very much encourage you guys
at home do you stop pause the video here
see if you can find the only winning
move or white it is such a beautiful
move by Karpov in this case and it's why
this game is sort of a brilliancy or
Karpov 52 moves deep okay hopefully you
guys got it
it's the move and that made me think to
go over this game as Fabi played in his
game against Roger Bobb earlier this
year
the move Bishop h6 in fabi's game it
actually turned that his Bishop h6 was a
mistake under very very similar
circumstances in this case so ever it is
in fact the winning move you counter one
threat to a queen with another threat to
a queen and point out the fact that this
queen is very much overworked this
Bishop on h6 is untouchable
due to Queen takes f3 and in fact
incredibly Bishop h6 was also playable
in this position
Unity's h6 would have been met by rook G
takes g6 with same the same ideas of
diverting this Queen away from the rook
and a victory but works e7 first was
played in this case and this is enough
for a win there's simply no way to solve
these threats if you move this Queen out
of the way there's really no good
squares for it to go to Bishop g7 coming
on the board and if you take this Queen
as played in the game some Bishop takes
that fate check up check over takes
takes d3 and black resigned in this game
of course King takes g1 would be a bit
of a mistake as d2 would be queening but
this is not forced by any means with any
number of moves being able to stop this
pawn and this pawn queening for white
simply up a piece what a games from
Anatoly Karpov and Gary Kasparov here
this was truly a battle of titans and a
super super complex middlegame position
where both sides had threats on both
sides of the board this was an
incredibly fun game hopefully you guys
enjoyed it and enjoyed that finishing
tactics by Karpov to win the game as
always my name is Caleb Denby and I will
see you next time